[Musique]
bienvenue à tous dans cette édition
spéciale du journal de l'afrique
entièrement consacrées au décès de la
reine d'angleterre et des liens que
celle-ci entretenait avec les pays
africains
bienvenue
soixante dix ans de règne le deuxième le
plus long de l'histoire débuta en 1952
au kenya c'était en afrique elisabeth
devint reine vingt-quatre heures après
son décès nous verrons quels sont les
liens qu'entretenait la reine elizabeth
ii avec le continent africain nous nous
interrogerons sur le poids et la force
du commonwealth dont une vingtaine de
pays africains commonwealth qu'elle a
juré de servir toute sa vie avec nos
invités virginie roiron maîtresse de
conférences en civilisation britannique
à l'université de strasbourg spécialiste
du commonwealth et nous aurons aussi
francis patindé journaliste et
professeur à sciences po paris merci à
vous deux alors elizabeth ii s'est
éteinte ce jeudi en écosse après 70 ans
de règne et c'est en afrique qu'elle
devint reine en 1952 lors d'un voyage au
kenya un continent qui tiendra une place
particulière dans la vie de celle qui
agiraient est déclarée desdites de
dédier toute sa vie à toutes les nations
du commonwealth
retour sur ses liens historiques avec
cyril b
elle s'est couchée princesse et s'est
réveillée rennes un moment qu elizabeth
ii a vécu alors qu'elle séjournait à
trip topps au kenya avec son mari dans
la nuit du 5 au 6 février 1952 le roi
georges si succombé à un cancer du
poumon dans l'est de l'angleterre sa
fille elisabeth prend alors directement
ses nouvelles fonctions alors qu'elle se
trouve sur le continent africain pour
une tournée dans les pays du
commonwealth elle apprend la nouvelle
plus de 24 heures après le décès de son
père alors qu'elle s'accordait avec le
duc d'edimbourg une nuit loin de ses
obligations officielles dans un pavillon
d'observation de la faune l'afrique l'a
rennes l'a retrouvera deux ans plus tard
dans le cadre d'un grand périple à
travers le commonwealth et c'est l'alibi
qu'elle choisit pour faire son premier
voyage officiel sur le continent depuis
son couronnement à tobrouk elle
rencontre le droit idriss qui sera le
dernier monarque du pays contre l'avis
de nombreux politiques dont winston
churchill alors à la tête des
conservateurs elizabeth ii se rend en
1961 dans la première colonie africaine
à devenir indépendante quatre ans plus
tôt le ghana d'elizabeth ii et à accra
on retiendra cette danse qu'elle a
accordé au président panafricain kwamé
n'krumah un geste perçu comme une marque
de considération par le président
ghanéen à l'époque l'objectif pour la
reine est de conserver au maximum les
liens avec cette ancienne colonie et
limiter l'influencé soviétique dans ce
pays dix huit ans plus tard là encore
une visite qui fait les gros titres des
conseillers par l'entourage de la
monarque et notamment la première
ministre margaret thatcher
elizabeth ii insiste pour se rendre en
zambie à l'occasion du 5e meeting des
chefs de gouvernement du commonwealth
dans un contexte sécuritaire très tendue
dans un pays limitrophe de la rhodésie
du sud en pleine guerre civile la reine
président la signature de la déclaration
de lusaka sur le racisme et les
discriminations
un texte qui établit l'égalité raciale
sur le plan légal et condamnent
l'apartheid en afrique du sud et
l'afrique du sud justement la monarque
ne foulent son sol qu'en 1995 pour la
première fois depuis le début de son
règne la seconde depuis 1947 lors de sa
première visite c'est là qu'elle
prononce son premier discours de
princesse héritière
je déclare devant vous tous que toute ma
vie qu'elle soit longue ou courte sera
consacré à votre service et au service
de notre grande famille impériale à
laquelle nous appartenons tous
48 ans plus tard le contexte politique
est bien différent l'apartheid a pris
fin et l'afrique du sud vient de
réintégrer le commonwealth devant nelson
mandela à port elizabeth la reine prend
la parole et exhorte la jeunesse sud
africaine à reconstruire sa nation
elle félicite également la population
d'avoir réussi en douceur sa transition
vers la démocratie
virginie roiron merci d'être dans cette
édition spéciale justement sur france 24
et on en profite on continue cette
émission spéciale consacrée au décès de
la reine d'angleterre
pourriez-vous nous dire justement ce que
représentait le continent africain pour
la reine d'angleterre dont on le précise
assez souvent ce les idées politiques
filtrer peu on ne sait pas beaucoup de
ce que pense la reine mais que peut
représenter le continent africain pour
elle alors pour elle c'était un enjeu
déjà un enjeu parce que
quand elle est devenue reine la
décolonisation avait déjà était déjà
intervenue en asie donc l'inde était
devenue indépendante ce nouveau
commonwealth à vous venez d'être créée
en 1949 en tant que institution née de
lempire et l'enjeu en fait c'était de
faire en sorte que les colonies future
indépendance
deviennent des membres du commonwealth
et en ce qui concerne le contient
africain ce n'était pas quelque chose
qui était gagné donc il il était il faut
savoir quand elle est devenue reine en
52 c'était au moment de la répression
des marots mao au kenya donc on n'était
pas du tout dans une danse est dans
cette idée là et finalement donc de la
transition qui s'est fait à la fin des
années 50 au début des années 60 sur le
commonwealth qui est devenu plus
multiraciale et elle a su l'accompagner
et de ce fait elle a accompagné aussi
l'unité du golfe en tant que chef du
commonwealth la reine était le symbole
de l'unité du commonwealth et en ce sens
là on peut dire que l a contribué à
cette unité là on l'a vu dans le votre
reportage avec le danse avec kwame
nkrumah donc ça c'est symbolique tout un
tas de petits gestes symboliques en tant
que chef du commonwealth qui qui ont
contribué à l'unité de cette
organisation qui était très très
informel quand même et qui n'était pas
forcément
un du couac et luis calais absolument il
a fallu son quérir sa voix francis
patindé de l'autre côté donc du côté
africain on a vu une reine quand même
assez populaire notamment auprès de ces
sujets qui font partie de la du
commonweath comment vous expliquez ça
été dit que son accession au pouvoir
coïncide avec la sidération des luttes
faut les indépendances il ya eu des cas
où ça s'est plutôt bien passé dans le
cas du ghana donc en 1957 eni n'était
pas ses terres a ajouté la duchesse de
kent qui la représentait mais il y avait
martin luther king déjà comme ça qu'ils
étaient allés dépendantes ça s'est
plutôt bien passé même s'il ya eu des
cas d'emprisonnement mais hier le cas
que vous citez tout à leurs cadets kenya
où ça s'est mal passé parce que la
révolte des mario marois commencé en
1950 de l'année où elle accédait au
pouvoir des s'est terminée autour d'eux
avec les éditions de détente kimathi en
56 voyez donc et le problème c'est qu'il
ya eu des massacres énorme par les
troupes britanniques et le supplétif et
on parle de 100 mille morts il y a des
dents le climat thiais a été pendu il ya
beaucoup dehors et des sujets qui ont
été pendus mais on n'a pas la pente du
la reine moufter on n'a pas entendu à la
reine juste poussé un soupir de
désapprouver c'est pas à elle de faire
la politique nationale c'est ça
appartient au gouvenement au premier
ministre mais en aurait on aurait pu
s'attendre au vu de ces massacres dans
la plus belle des colonies de l'une des
plus belles colonies africaines de 2
de la monarchie britannique haskell ou
sketches ou qu'elle le connaît sa
désapprobation n'a pas parlé on en
reviendra là dessus je vous propose
d'aller en afrique du sud pays qu'elle a
visité deux fois une première fois en 47
alors qu'elle était princesse et que le
pays est une colonie britannique en 95
tandis que nelson mandela était au
pouvoir ses relations avec le plus vieux
prisonnier du monde était bien connue
des explications de notre correspondante
qui a vécu ces années là caroline dumay
c'est une image qui restera sans doute
dans la mémoire des sud-africains la
reine elizabeth 2 qui arrive par bateau
et qui est accueilli en 1995 par nelson
mandela les deux personnalités se
saluent ben alors en fait comme si elles
ne s'étaient jamais quittés on sait
qu'elles se connaissent un peu la reine
avait d'ailleurs invité au nelson
mandela au sommet du commun nous en
1991 alors qu'il n'était même pas chef
d'état elle ne s'était jamais vraiment
prononcé contre l'apartheid mais on la
disait sympathisante des mouvements de
libération alors en 95 on a l'impression
qu'en fait une relation particulière est
en train de s'installer entre ces deux
personnalités la reine lui remet une
décoration et de la même décoration
qu'elle avait remise à à mère teresa
l'année suivante nelson mandela va en
visite officielle à londres on sait
qu'ils vont beaucoup ce téléphoner on a
aussi appris qu'il y avait eu une
correspondance entre les deux
personnalités des lettres que la reine
elizabeth ii d'ailleurs à conserver et
puis surtout un elson mandela était le
seul à appeler la reine par son prénom
et un jour on lui a demandé pourquoi ils
enfreignaient les guerres règles du
protocole et il a répondu écoutez si
elle m'appelle nelson je peux bien
l'appeler elisabeth
virginie oiron francis patindé disait
justement que son silence était
assourdissant sur but sur en parlant du
kenya et de la révolte des mains en
mains mais aussi on a analysé finalement
son absence koulal le platine le temps
qu'elle a mis pour retourner en afrique
du sud comme son désaveu de l'apartheid
mais justement qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce
qu'on s'est vraiment de ce
repositionnement sur ces questions là
alors on ne sait pas elle n'a pas mais
en revanche elle a accompagné comme je
le disais tout à l'heure le l'évolution
du commonwealth et comme elle tenait à
la pérennité de cette organisation
qu'elle avait juré de servir elle parle
bien dans votre reportage on le voyait
elle parlait de cette famille impériale
qui est devenue la famille du
commonwealth on voit bien le la
continuité pour elle et l'importance que
cela pouvait avoir et donc elle a donc
elle a accompagné cette évolution du
commonwealth en d'organisation
multiraciale donc c'était quelque chose
qui était décidée par les membres par le
processus de décolonisation le fait que
les membres africains sont devenus ont
choisi de devenir membre du commonwealth
et ensuite les les autres dans les
années soixante dix les petits états ont
également accepté de venir membres de
cette organisation internationale
donc il fallait accompagner cela le
commonwealth avait changé le colonel
n'était plus un club de blanc comme on
l'avait pas des comme c'était le cas
après la guerre donc ça l a accompagnée
est ce que elle l'approuvé ou pas ça on
ne peut pas le savoir ouais voilà mais
elle l'a accompagnée et elle a fait en
sorte que par des gestes symboliques
elle représente ce nouveau commonwealth
c'est tout ce qu'on peut dire que
d'ailleurs on va écouter d'autres
réactions de ces sujets de la majesté
notamment au nigeria pays le plus peuplé
du continent africain première économie
africaine au sein du commonwealth et on
en parle juste après
j'ai été très triste d'apprendre son
décès mais j'ai aussi célébrer sa vie
comme un symbole de leadership un
symbole de paix je me souviens que nous
a offert notre indépendance sur un
plateau d'or et j'en suis reconnaissant
et bien sûr que son âme repose en
parfaite
factice jadona baisse elle a fait de son
mieux et elle nous a passé le relais
alors je vous souhaite simplement peuple
un dogue le ter le meilleur
néanmoins c'est une période de réflexion
profonde elle a vécu une vie dont tout
le monde profite d'une manière ou d'une
autre du rabbin d'asus
francis patindé on voit les hommages qui
fleurissent notamment justement dans ces
zones là
le commonwealth attire quand même on a
vu que le gabon et le togo sont rentrés
après le rwanda comme on explique que
quand même il ya cet attrait pour le
commonwealth en afrique à mon sens un
luthier passe à halle à l'image de la
reine la reine elle est relativement
respecter les mêmes adulé dans certains
pays africains mais ça tient à autre
chose
sa ronde plus loin ça tient la manière
dont les britanniques ont quitté
l'afrique ils ont largué les amarres
contrairement à d'autres puissances
européennes qui sont restés qui ont fait
mille deux parties mais qui sont restés
les britanniques sont partis on ne parle
pas triés par exemple une monnaie le
monep au stand alone ya des femmes qui
est arrimée à la banque d'angleterre la
banque centrale d'angleterre et il n'y a
pas de base sur bloc continental
aujourd'hui a pas de base britannique
vous savez il ya d'autres puissances qui
ont plusieurs bases sur le continent
francis m'a dit de parler de la france
clairement parler de la france ferment
délai la dernière intervention
britanniques en afrique et remonte à
c'était en sierra leone c'était au
moment le roof l'europe le le mouvement
rebelle il front révolutionnaire uni
voulait prendre à freetown la capitale
de sierra leone il y avait des risques
énormes parce que c'est des fous furieux
les gens durs où les britanniques sont
intervenus sont restés deux ans et se
sont retirés ce n'est pas le cas de la
france par exemple qu'il est je crois
que l'attractivité de la du commonweath
tsévié dalmat cela et beaucoup de
francophones fantasme ou bien où l'on
rêve d intégrer le commando mais alors
justement est-ce que c'est intéressant
ce terme de fantasmes est ce que
justement
j'allais dire est-ce que l'herbe est
vraiment plus verte du côté du
commonwealth comme voilà tu lire jenny
wolf hall c'est une organisation
ex-amant informel qui est à la fois
internationale intergouvernementale et
transnationale c'est à dire qu'en fait
la force du commonwealth et son réseau
et finalement ce réseau qui ferme et 2
bah commercer plus facilement et c'est
donc je pense que ça ça une vraie force
d'attraction quand on est un marché
prometteur comme l'afrique on voit par
exemple quand on voit le gouvernement
britannique dira qu' il veut être le
pays du g7 qui va le plus investir en
afrique
là on voit l'intérêt du commonwealth et
on voit aussi le avec ce qu'on dise tout
est alors hors antenne le rwanda
l'attrait du rwanda qui qui est qui est
extrêmement important aussi donc vous
pour vous le rwanda a joué un rôle pour
justement attirer je le pense voilà
après je pense aussi qu'il ya ce
potentiel donc de
relations commerciales
et qui et puis surtout le commonwealth
est une organisation qui est totalement
international c'était il n'ya pas
d'organe supranationale alors malgré le
fait que le commonwealth se dit on va
parmi ces valeurs et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'il est beaucoup critiqué
la défense des droits de l'homme la
démocratie etc il n'ya pas d'organe qui
intervient dans la politique des états
etc c'est c'est quelque chose de très
important à mon sens pour des pays qui
ont été colonisés et qui ont qui ont qui
ont soif de cette souveraineté et cette
indépendance mais justement est-ce qu
avec l'accession au trône du nouveau roi
donc charles iii est ce que cette vision
va changer on sait peu finalement 2-2 ce
qu'ils pensent de l'afrique le prince
charles on l'a entendu beaucoup sur
l'environnement l'écologie et c'est à
mes nombreuses du continent africain mon
sens ça ne va pas changer ça ne changera
pas le commonwealth fonctionne avec ses
chefs d'état et de gouvernement ouais
c'est c'est ça qui fait le moteur du
commonwealth actuellement il ya un
symbole c'est le symbole de l'unité ont
fait des discours sur la famille du
commonwealth et c est de ce point de vue
là le chef du commonwealth est
symbolique
les états du commonwealth ont accepté
que charles devienne chef du
commonwealth en 2018 ce n'était pas
acquis ce n'est pas un titre héréditaire
bon mais c'est symbolique ce qui fait
marcher le commonwealth sait les
relations entre les états et et et au 6
août sous ce réseau d'organisations non
gouvernementales
d'associations etc qui crée du lien
enfin en dessous en fait ouais enfin au
niveau infra étatique de l'autonomie
aussi les états sont assez autonomes à
la différence soit aussi
de la zone du pré carré français on l'a
bien entendu merci merci beaucoup
francis patine d merci c'est là et merci
aussi à virginie roiron qui est venu
justement sur ce plateau c'est la fin de
cette émission spéciale retourna de
l'afrique entièrement consacrées au
décès de la reine d'angleterre merci à
caroline dumay à nos invités francis
patine d'énergie noire on merci à alain
gaudin d'avoir eu des repas par et cette
édition spéciale merci à vous tous de
nous avoir suivi on se quitte sur ces
images de la reine elizabeth ii décédé
ce jeudi à l'âge de 96 ans après 70 ans
de règne sur des millions de sujets à
travers les 56 pays du commonwealth tôt
21 pays africains
[Musique]
hp berraf détail âge menaçait de briser
nova soit 6,3 majesty de couy cher aux
femmes et à la 9ème place à des chevaux